um lyrically like on some MC [ __ ] I feel
like you're like top-notch man I feel
like you're especially on the west coast
like when I think of like I look
yeah like when I think like like who can
melt somebody on a 16 oh my god mozzies
one of those guys like who is somebody
who you respect on that level as like a
rapper who like even like yo man not
like if you were to do a record with you
might be worth to surf you guys are the
whole project together whole project
he's one of them people that I get in
there and you know it's a spicy
situation you know I'm Sammy we it's
funky smoke I'm saying and uh you know I
know he's gonna dish it out and so I got
a return fire he go brazii
who else I respect on that level outside
of my camp I'm saying cuz you know the
selling rules he go great according to
eat my nerves
this them them they all competitive and
they make but um yeah I say surfing them
you know Nick I used to feel that way
about a hundred percent G OD like I got
a tweak when I get in here with him I
can't ain't no plan would it it was one
more oh my boy j-rock I respect what a
rock of course I respect rocking away he
rock out
it's a cup I respect a lot of people
that be shooting that is a man I ain't
gonna lie some people that that could
dance in that booth you talk about
j-rock obviously Kendrick putting you on
that Black Panther soundtrack was a big
look man was there ever any dialogue of
you signing with TD ego is that
discussion ever happened like today ever
like show interest cuz I feel like you
would have fit in tte function with me I
think a lot of I didn't do me so many
out of you man and I can't wait to
return the favor
G OD I feel like I'm in debt with them
people man love them
was there ever like any discussions are
you signing signing with it I was you
know I was I was throwing that out there
brotherbrother
but we saw family-oriented that you know
it nobody we ain't never pressed play on
that and you know I'm so bumped a bow
and bully boo with my little situation
that I never really entertained anything
outside of it but
for sure I function with the whole tve
camping uh that'd be dope